c'est un dimanche parfait pour faire
campagne un soleil radieux réchauffe
trois rivières la capitale de la
mauricie pour yves lévesque qu'il a
dirigée pendant dix sept ans l'occasion
est inespéré la ville inaugure son
nouveau colisée effectivement ça tombe
bien c'est un des projets qu'on a fait
at war et bien on a fait beaucoup est
arrivé troisième en 2019 dans une course
où l'écart entre la première et la
troisième place était de seulement 3%
l'ex-maire reconnu pour être aussi
populaire que polarise ans n'a pas dit
son dernier mot on connaît l'homme mais
le parti plus sûr je peux pas je peux
pas dire si c'est mieux
c'est un maillage
site a confessé un mois là et courbettes
le bloc sert à rien pi parti libéral
sont partis
peu connus dans la région l'éthicien
owni villemur espère succéder à sa
collègue louise charbonneau qui avait
créé la surprise en remportant trois
rivières au coude à coude avec les
libéraux et conservateurs il y a deux
c'est comme partout au pays l'économie
et l'environnement préoccupe les
trifluviens la question posée au chef
bloquiste lors du débat en anglais n'est
pas passée inaperçue dans cette ville où
96 % de la population est francophone
d'ailleurs à rendre les citoyens puisque
la première chose gens même de loin pour
bâtir les rues alors oui c'est en effet
la table le débat nadège et j'ai trouvé
ça dégueulasse un petit peu confirmé des
choix c'est en tant que québécois c'est
ce qu'elle nous parle un peu plus mais
on va décider la journée tout cas
même s'il bénéficie d'une certaine
notoriété
la campagne du libéral ex éditorialiste
au quotidien local est plombée par ses
critiques passées sur justin trudeau et
richard friedland martin francoeur
insiste après 28 ans dans l'opposition
il est temps pour trois-rivières d'avoir
une voix à ottawa on a la chance de
faire avancer trois rivières d'un autre
côté un adversaire conservateur axe
présente dans un parti aux idées
rétrogrades
or on voit bien que volume ce n'est pas
trop loin derrière le peloton de tête à
disney déjà arrivé au canada en tant que
réfugiés de la bosnie herzégovine à
l'âge de 9 ans aimerait bien se faufiler
en tête je le rappelle toujours on est
la septième circonscription avec le plus
faible taux de revenu par médiapart
ménages le néo démocrate qui se présente
comme le défenseur des minorités et des
plus vulnérables incarne un certain
renouveau politique
nous ce qu'on veut c'est faire sortir le
vote conservateur small journée
bloquiste pendant presque deux décennies
puis emporté par la vague orange
l'humeur des électeurs triple vient est
souvent un bon indicateur des grandes
tendances nationales
à quelques jours des élections les
indécis sont encore nombreux bien malin
qui pourrait prédire quelles couleurs
prendra à trois rivières et le reste du
pays ici amélie démarré à radio canada
trois rivières